hey youtubers is truly think your
minutes many questions for this week's
walking to a CUNY
generally my questions about what's
going to be happening with Beth
as well as the other people that showed
up in the episode that end credits scene
ideas and theories about how said person
ended up in the hospital I think it's
personally on purpose
but episode 6 is when they're planning
and explain that so
cover spoilers from the absurd if you're
not cut yet but here we go
question number one stocking ask when it
comes to paying back where you know how
do they determine the value everything
I think largely diane is the one
determines value
it seem like what they were applying is
is that that more your word
the more you have to pay back like Don
wants to keep people there who are worth
a lot
people that serve highly critical
functions that's where the doctor was so
quick to try and get rid of that other
doctor
so that he would be higher value as we
would bet those I think that's largely
determine undervalued the medicine they
gave her
you could call a little bit a commentary
on the health care system in that they
give her very little care
but they're charging her a lot for
people that live in international
country's health care in america is
extremely expensive we don't have
universal health care
that's why some people can go bankrupt
from staying in hospital too long
even if Don is playing it fast and loose
with what she's asking people to pay
back
are telling them what they owe I do
think that she has a system in her head
she seems like a fairly analytical
person even if she's operating on false
information
but the false hope that people are going
to come rescuer question number two
did Leslie s did officer nasty not bad
out in taker
based on with the other girl was saying
it seem like the police were stealing
people
not saving them yes it didn't seem like
used trying to get his own law here I'm
going
I think they randomly crosses past but
when he did see her
he thought that she make a nice addition
so he just clutter and threw in the back
at the car
CS I'm firmly coming down on the side
bet being kidnapped
question re 3 Extreme Pro ass wise care
at the hospital
so there's a couple theories so the
first one is is that she and Daryl
follow that car with a cross on it and
she infiltrated the hospital
by getting yourself heard the other
theories is that she and Daryl got in a
fight with them
or other people in the police found her
and brought her in
as for why daryl is not there
I think that whenever the fight is that
they got in or whatever their plane was
they tried to get away in carol was
taken i think is really combination
about those things
I think they took off after their car
they've got took bed
got into a really sticky situation think
carol saw how it was going to go down
in just let it happen thinking that she
might be able to find that that way
but they were in a losing situation and
she let them get away just like beth let
no one get away
I think there'll be some parallels
between Beth Noah
Darrell in Carroll question number for a
90 s
d think that Morgan is the uncle Noah
said he's looking for
I think that would be an awfully big
coincidence but it would be really cool
stackable was really quite about Morgan
story line this season
it's gonna happen separate from everyone
else for at least the most part
just because so many things feel like
they're converging at the hospital for
this midseason finale
I do think that morgan's gonna come in a
place I do think it'll turn out that he
is somehow connected to the no character
dismissed or 8i perspective if you're
sitting in the writers room
at Walking Dead in you want people to go
is not as possible during the mid-season
finale
what would you do first you have a big
battle at the hospital
any bring Morgan back in full on right
here with giant weapons
it just feels like something that they
want to go out on for the mid-season
break
which number five Dexter ask do you
think over the course of the season Beth
will start to be more like crazy Rick
you go north on everyone in the hospital
so
I think there's two ways the best story
like to go down 1
she could toughen up and helpers of
escape
to she could end up dying or sacrifice
yourself for people at the hospital
both those scenarios our heroes arcs for
her character I think that's what they
have her own right now like she slowly
becoming
just as valuable as all the other
survivors of the badasses
when is pretty straight up badass he
wrote the other is a tragic hero story
line
so it depends on how tragic you think
that's character is I think we won't
learn more about what's going to happen
with her for a couple more episodes
at least until we follow up with Carol
those two characters
arguably I think carol is the more
tragic one so I think that Beth would
get out in that scenario
care will be the one to die
it's a little early to make guesses so
those are just the res right now
no matter what the scenario ends up
being I don't think that she's gonna go
crazy
like she's not gonna bite anyone snake
out which number six
simply as many went crazy trying to find
land but she hasn't mentioned that once
that we know up what's up with that yes
Emily Kinney address this on talking
dead
she said you know I get it she's got her
boyfriend that she found n cheese
just concentrating on trying to stay
alive elected the actress that plays bed
is apologizing for Maggie if they dont
this long without baggy mentioning bed
I don't think that it's gonna come up
anytime soon anything is possible
abraham's group
will have a scene somewhere where maggie
will find something that reminds her bed
image a POS int think about it but it
might all be internalized
question number seven Mike s what if
Rick knows the police officers in the
hospital
yet so team county was pretty near
atlanta so it's possible he knows some
those people
there are some people hypothesizing that
this person in this picture here
is officer lerner in the fictional
history the show created for she's an
original character
they didn't say anything about being a
share from King County so I don't think
he's directly connected to Rick
I think they will draw some parallels
between her character in Rick's
character cuz they're both officers law
trying to do what they think is right
even though I do think that officer
lerner
is a villain in the hospital the twist
is is that she's operating from a very
rational plays
the need order in rule to survive the
need resources they need to preserve
those
she has a system that she's created it
kinda works she's trying to maintain it
I think what we need to watch out for is
for her to completely snap
during that pose credits each she
snapped a little bit but I think that
was just a momentary break or it could
be
foreshadowing for I think it would be a
disservice to make the care to go
completely nuts
I think it they did that would just be
another version the governor would just
be them recycling old material
be like another Woodbury
question number eight his US had to keep
finding so much food should all be
expired by now
so they're still working generators
giving power to the city where their
freezers with
food in it I don't really know kinda
generators they have operating around
Atlanta
but if they do have a nuclear power
plant nearby then they have power
indefinitely
these had to keep it operational so in
terms of food spoiling P still have ways
to preserve it
in there's the journals the journal meat
was just a call back to the media
terminus
you know what you need whenever he
offered it to bed and started talking
about it I thought that maybe where
they're getting
all their me like their breeding
durables for me which number nine
urban 2s what's going on with the ANC
and DirecTV they're having a carriage
deal dispute
in EMC is threatening to take their
channels of the air
most other channels now them the same
thing happened last year with dish
for those that don't know this is really
just the United States being so
international people shouldn't be
affected by this
anyone that does not have DirecTV
doesn't have to worry about it either
EMC and DirecTV haven't reached a
financial arrangement for renewing their
contract
if you do have DirecTV though I totally
feel for you don't worry
the supply be resolved fairly soon
question ever 10
daily just let me ask do you think that
know it feels bad about leaving but
behind
I totally think you'll feel bad I think
whenever they lead the charge to go back
and get her
he'll be on that team from the little we
did see even he seems like a fairly
positive person he doesn't seem like a
coward like Eugene Ore the doctor
I know a lot of your SMU how long he's
going to be on the show he's not a
series regular
but I do think it's plain his contract
if they wanna make in a series regular
later
as far as I know though he's only going
to be in a couple episodes this season
thank you so much for so many questions
as always it on a plan to do I think
general artist
waiting to see what is going to happen
with care on bed congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner
hunter murdoch you in the Amazon gift
card just contact me on my channel or
summer on social like Facebook or
Twitter for details
again next week's episode is going to be
all about the DC crew so be sure to
subscribe to get my video
find out whatever him
his mustache you're doing so occasion
see it
even click here for my episode for video
in you can click here
for last week's episode 3 video thank
you so much watching sought help at all
CS tonight